Okay, so we've talked a lot about specific lighting setups,
but we've not really talked too much about reflections.
So part of what makes a convincing lighting solution
are gonna be the reflections.
So let's go ahead and take a look
at what we're gonna be looking at
with this section of the course.
I will be taking a look at reflection pros themselves
and when to use them,
the types of reflections that you can get,
scenarios for reflections,
the building quality of the reflections themselves
and some tips and tricks.
So when should we use reflection captures?
They're to be used with primarily reflective surfaces
more than anything.
And the idea is to give the illusion
of a believable reflective material or substance.
If you do not use the reflection capture actor,
as you can see here,
Unreal is gonna go ahead
and use screen space reflection as a default.
Using a reflection capture will create
and give you more detailed believable reflections.
And you can find this actor
under modes and visual effects.
The types that can be used are the followed,
screen space reflections that are gonna be the default,
spherical reflections,
box reflections and planar reflections.
Now it's important to understand
that reflection captures are only needed
when you're using light mass and bacon lighting.
They are not needed for ray traced reflections,
but they can help.
They have real time reflections when using ray tracing
and no re-bacon is needed,
but a hybrid of both can be used
to help performance if you need to.
Now, what type of reflections can you have?
You have screen space reflections.
So it's Unreal Engine 5's old default reflections system.
We now use Lumen.
Lumen reflections are actually now gonna be on
probably by default,
but you can edit them in this case
by creating a post-process volume
and you can control the intensity, quality and roughness.
To affect the whole scene,
you just need to set your post-process volume
to infinite bounce.
And it's just one column below
on the screen space settings.
You've got sphere and box reflections.
They're used when baking lights.
You can control the influence and radius
of how strong the range of reflection can be.
By default, the source type is set to captured scene
and you can customize the reflection via a cube map
if you wanna add your own cube map
that you've generated yourself.
It's important to note that the reflection capture
will use the texture as a source
and the brightness can be controlled
if you find that your reflections are a little bit too dark.
So it is a fairly versatile system.
We also got planar reflections.
UE4 and now UE5 also have support
for real-time planar reflections,
which can give you more accurate reflections
than screen space reflections.
And they're actually really good
for flat surfaces like water, for example.
The higher render cost
this particular type of reflection is due to how they work.
They actually render the level again
on the opposite direction of the reflection.
So that's one thing to keep in mind
that planar reflection is fairly expensive
due to its nature.
You also got scenarios.
The use case for these is pretty logical
based on the reflection type.
If your model is square in nature
and the reflection is close to the original shape,
you can use a box reflection
and then you can also use a sphere reflection
if you have some more curved surfaces
or highly distorted surfaces
like puddles, water, glasses, glass sculpture,
anything like that that you can think of.
The sphere capture will always have a curve on the edge
that may be seen at the right angle.
But again, keep that in mind.
It's if you don't have a highly reflective surface,
it's not gonna be a huge issue,
but just keep that in mind.
Now, when it comes to quality control
and building settings that we need to keep in mind,
every time you move, create or delete
a reflection capture, you'll have to rebuild
because they get all converted into an atlas essentially.
Unreal Engine will automatically rebuild reflections
when you build lights.
So that's something to keep in mind.
So, and this is kind of handy as well,
but you can build reflections on their own.
To control the resolution of your reflections,
you need to go to your project settings
and set them to 1K or 2K if you need higher quality.
But this is something you really only need
if you're trying to go for a photorealistic setting
and also if you're using a ray trace hybrid.
So, tips that I can give you
when it comes to reflections.
They're not calculated in any ray trace scenario.
So it's a bit of an illusion of detail.
But again, it's a good fallback to get quality.
But overall, it's useful for baking lights.
When custom making your own reflections,
just keep in mind, do not go too high with the resolution.
Keeping it at 1K or 2K is the most ideal
since the higher resolution, the higher the cost.
And in most cases, unless you have
in mirror-like surfaces, you can get away
with sort of blurrier reflections in general.
So just keep that in mind.